oh crap Oh God I like really white
beautify does that imply that I'm not
already beautiful skin
that's a weird option to have I kind of
already predict I know what's gonna
happen I'm gonna get super pale wait
there's a filter called whitening
where's the tanning filter okay we'll go
all the way with the whites and my mom
would appreciate that she doesn't like
me being tan a lot of people in India
like to use skin lighteners but I think
dark Santa's really pretty definitely
just stripped my brown this away oh my
god my skin looks so much better select
the area you want to stretch I don't
want to stretch anything out kind of
just made my boob bigger which I don't
know how I feel about that oh my face
was this big beforehand oh my God look
at my cheeks tapped remove acne all
right well I was PMSing this week so I
know exactly where I'm breaking out it
only takes this small oh my god it's
like just lifting my moles away I'm
basically like doing plastic surgery
virtually on my face right now like I
predicted there was an eye enlarged name
tool do a lot of people want their eyes
cuz it's a don't oh my god this is like
so much cheaper than surgery if they
looked like an alien the difference is
so subtle but also so noticeable when
you look at the before and after oh okay
I'm gonna hit Auto retouch and I'm kind
of super nervous to see what happens so
it's weird because the longer you look
at it the more normal it looks and
that's really terrifying this is just
it's not me this app definitely shows
how different the beauty standards are
here compared to Asia
I feel like an American
this would probably like make your
eyebrows on fleek
they would definitely be a tool that
would give you like big full Kylie
Jenner lips I think the biggest
difference is that people in Asia want
lighter skin apparently I don't think
I'd use it to fix myself or make myself
more beautiful in an image but it was
fun to play with and I would play it
like a game
I am half Indian and I have dark skin
and I wouldn't trade it for anything I
mean it's not you at the end of the day
like a pictures I mean the picture is
supposed to be you I love how like the
Kardashian clan is basically America
standard of beauty it's like the whole
family has some kind of trait they were
all trying to like emulate